[Music]
so
hello everybody and welcome to age of
empires a fan
preview i'm zach robinson although you
probably know me
better as zero empires thanks for
joining us here in the town center
with our good friend barbarossa we're
all really excited
and even though we can't be around each
other right now we're thrilled to have
you here
even just virtually but we're especially
excited for you to
finally get a look at everything new we
have to share
for age of empires today will be a
celebration of age of empires and we're
going to show you
tons of stuff you've never seen before
with our first ever looks at age of
empires 4
including a new campaign never before
seen civilizations
new updates for our age vampires
definitive edition games
and of course lots and lots of gameplay
after the show visit the virtual village
at age of empires dot com
where you'll be able to explore and
discover even more
about age of empires 4 with photo ops
digital downloads and exclusive content
from the game
i can tell you everyone who's been
working on this beloved franchise has
been pouring their souls into it
for years and when you're involved in
something this great
sometimes the hardest part is not
telling anyone about it
well today that's over we know you're
dying to see it and we're not going to
make you wait any longer
because we've got a whole lot of show to
get through so let's kick things off
by getting a very first look at one of
the brand new playable civilizations
in age of empires 4.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're starting with elephants and i can
tell you it only gets bigger from here
now we're about to look at the reveal
for one of the four new campaigns for
age of empires for
history is the hard-fought road
from ambition
to victory
it molds warriors into kings
and heralds the rise of empires
the year is 10 66
harold king of the anglo-saxons rules
england
but his crown has been promised to
another contender
duke william of normandy
while harold fends off viking raiders in
the north
william crosses the english channel
intent
on seizing the throne the two rivals
would clash
at the battle of hastings
[Applause]
but one battle does not win a war
and power once grasped can be
easily lost in the north
the peasantry rebels against a king they
do not recognize
northern barons ally with viking
invaders and sees the city of york
william must act quickly to secure his
control
and his descendants will fight over the
crown
for decades to come
in a bloody contest on both sides of the
channel
normandy is besieged
civil war erupts and would-be kings
wrestle for control of both england and
france
[Music]
[Applause]
the norman conquest still echoes across
the ages
in stone and story
and it's just one such tale
in the age of empires
and remember that's just one of the four
historic campaigns you'll experience in
age of empires 4.
you're seeing a lot of magic on the
screen today but what we don't always
see
is the hard work and passion that really
brings these games to life
right now let's go behind the scenes at
relic studios
to meet some of the people behind age of
empires 4.
let's go we are relic entertainment in
vancouver canada and we are at the
forefront of real-time strategy games
relic is one of the last bastions for
fans of real-time strategy games it's
really exciting to be surrounded by
people who've also been playing and in
some cases making these games for over a
decade
relic is a place of passion
collaboration
and creativity you know relicons are
highly collaborative so
this is a place where people come
together to make the very best real-time
strategy games
what i refer to as the team at relic has
really every discipline
every professional every department we
have uh
support partner teams finance it
communications tech services
hr recruiting everyone feels like part
of the same group of people
when we all decided that we were going
to work from home it was a pretty easy
decision to make although an
agonizing one but obviously health and
safety
and security is top of mind for us
working through the pandemic has been
challenging i think that's that's pretty
straightforward
for everyone to accept but i'm really
proud of the way that the team has
adapted to that
i'm excited i literally can't wait to
get it into the hands of the community i
think
the release is just the beginning for us
[Music]
we know that our best work comes from
being truly connected to the community
that's been living and breathing age of
empires since the very beginning more
than 20 years ago
you can't make a game like age of
empires 4 without the partnership of
players who
are as passionate about the game as you
are about developing it
so we formed the community council and
we've been working with that council
throughout game development to play test
the game
and provide valuable kind of feedback to
helping shape the game to where it is
today
you know all those insights kind of help
us deepen our understanding of our
players
and what they want to see at the end of
the day it's
the players who play our game
who are going to gauge whether it's a
fun game
whether it's a game that they want to
play and so we're not making the game
for ourselves
we're making this game for the community
there's a lot of new innovations in in
age of empires 4.
if you love campaign we've got a really
interesting and innovative way of
presenting the campaign to you this sort
of
modern documentary style that's really
going to allow us to connect history and
and game play you know if you're a
multiplayer player you know you engage
in the in the competitive scene
there's a bunch of really different and
very asymmetric sieves that
you know i think the franchise hasn't
seen before all of the civilizations
play very very differently
our vision is really to make sure that
we really cater to and understand like
what it is that
a wide set of diverse audience wants to
see in the game
and we don't just kind of design for a
specific subset
we worked closely with historians and
experts to make sure that we could
capture
the essence of the history that we're
striving to portray
and then internally within relic as well
we have a dedicated campaign
design team that are also working on
building the missions and they are doing
their
own research alongside the narrative
team and we have an art team that's
building all of these great sets for us
that matches with the history
and it's a big effort when you look at
the game every unit you play every
building you construct
every sound you hear every word you read
everything
is informed by history and built around
this we've done a great job
capturing the essence of the original
games
and and trying to translate those into a
modern context
we've created something that players
will be able to jump in and recognize
and then it gives them the kind of the
foundation to explore a lot of the new
things that are in the game
and find the things that they love this
is our biggest and most ambitious title
yet
and we can't wait for you to play it
a huge thank you to everyone at relic
for keeping the spirit of age of empires
alive and well
and for continuing to add even more
great content to the series
let's check out the new gameplay with a
very first look
at a new take on the chinese
civilization in age of empires 4.
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
certainly sounds like it's time to start
strategizing
when you fire up age of empires you get
the chance to relive
and rewrite history we've also loved
going back to our classic titles to
bring you our definitive editions
bringing these games to an established
and new age players
here's what's coming to the definitive
editions for more than two decades
together we've built simple villages
into massive kingdoms
in one of the most beloved real-time
strategy franchises of all time
age of empires we are proud to be part
of gaming history
and in the past three years we've helped
new gamers
pick up their own spears swords and
muskets
with age of empires one two and three
definitive editions we listen to you
the age community and your input has
truly helped us
create the best versions of age of
empires ever
today we're proud to announce even more
updates
coming to the age of empires definitive
collection
first coming this summer we are excited
to announce our second expansion
dawn of the dukes taking you to eastern
europe
in the age of empires 2 definitive
edition experience
with new campaigns and much more we're
also excited to announce that later this
year
age of empires 2 definitive edition is
getting co-op for the first time
we've hand-picked a specific set of
campaign missions
and historical battles to play with
friends and work together
toward victory we'll have more details
to share for both
updates in the months ahead and we have
more changes in store for age of empires
3
definitive edition as well on tuesday
april 13th
age of empires 3 d e will release its
first major update
the united states civilization this new
civilization includes a new
unique explorer a brand new home city
nine new units a brand new age up
mechanic
and so much more the united states
civilization will be available for free
for a limited time by completing a new
50 state challenge
or you can purchase directly on steam or
the windows store
and later this year h3de will be
showcasing
african civilizations as we begin work
on our brand new expansion
we will have more info to share soon so
stay tuned
there's more to come as we keep building
and improving on the legacy of age of
empires that began over 20 years ago
be sure to on downl
game pass the windows store or steam
today
the age of empires community is diverse
and vibrant
and one that i am so proud to be a part
of
this last year has been difficult and
age of empires has brought us together
even when we can't be face to face
whether you're a player
a creator or even a fan thank you for
making this community a great place to
be
let's take a look at you the community
this is a celebration of all things age
of empires
in 1997 24 years ago the very first age
vampires came to pc across the globe
and players got to play in age up from
the stone age to the iron age
first free computer game i played in the
late 90s was the regional age of empires
you know i made so many friends
i've become a part of this community my
life is different now because of age of
empires
something just sit down to and enjoy the
sense of culture the sense of history
now today we're helping gamers age up
from being farmers to empire builders
across the age of empires franchise
and it's all thanks to support and
passion of our players
is it age of empires dude
our community has been the driving force
behind the success of the age franchise
the games truly would not be what they
are today without you
helping us pave the way still looking in
corners to see if he might be hiding
boom boom boom boom boom hello everybody
you were here with us when we went
through a revival with aoe2hd
and came with us for the renaissance
that was our definitive edition we're
going to be doing definitive editions of
both of those titles this is actually
the most hair i've had
for probably 15 years
we've loved watching you grow with us
through every title
and we can't wait to see what you bring
to age of empires 4.
age of empires lets you rewrite history
as any civilization from all over the
world
so it's no surprise that our community
shows the same diversity
my name is patricia i'm from argentina
from serbia belgrade i'm dmitry and i'm
from russia
i'm odile and i'm 29 years old from
norway not only do you hail from all
corners of the map but also across
multiple generations could write or read
but i was playing hf empires and it was
totally awesome
we're so proud to have such a welcoming
and friendly community everything i know
about age i've learned from
the chats the community is a wealth of
knowledge you've also helped age
vampires explode into the esports world
players are you ready we fight till the
death i was going to ask your strategy
but that feels pretty good
this is intense to go to military units
who's got the most cave i don't think
kaiser wants to fight it just yet oh
it's close
though i mean he's losing his cab so
quickly okay let's go into game number
one
oh my goodness not only have you given
the world exciting gameplay you've also
given us some of the most memorable
moments in the age of empires history
what a huge moment for doubt here what a
performance in red bull walla
3 and the game is over we've seen this
outpouring of love for the age of
empires titles and it's kept our
development team around the globe
inspired they're always hard at work
poring through historical texts for
ideas to create
new gaming experiences for you to enjoy
and our community team has been
alongside you
ensuring every player new and old is
heard and is able to contribute
we want to keep the love going for many
years to come i now
crown you from the very beginning
you've battled and waged war to make
your mark in the history books
[Applause]
thank you for being part of the global
community that is age of empires
and now the moment you've all been
waiting for
you came here for it you're ready for it
we're taking an extended look
at age of empires 4 gameplay footage
this has been captured in engine and
looks absolutely
stunning i'm happy to tell you the wait
is finally over enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rips
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
favorite
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
incredible the way it all comes together
seeing those
massive armies fighting in the end the
delhi war elephants
the mongols packing up their town the
chinese fireworks from the nest of bees
i don't know about you but i cannot wait
to join you
in playing age event players 4 later
this year
age of empires 4 will be available
worldwide on windows 10
xbox game pass for pc and steam
and if you can't wait that long don't
worry there's a closed beta on the way
too
head over to age of employers.com to
become an age insider
for the chance to get in on all of the
fun for the next week only you can also
check out a virtual village with even
more info
about age 4 including downloads
exclusive content
and deep dives on some of the new
civilizations that you saw today
and if that's not enough we're
partnering with alienware to give away a
one-of-a-kind age of empires branded
liquid-cooled
aurora r11 desktop to one lucky age
insider
sweepstakes entry is only available for
a limited time to new
and existing age insiders in certain
regions
so head to age of empires.com to enter
and for more information
what a show but we aren't done just yet
here's a recap of what we've seen today
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us especially
our little friends here in the town
center
and uh thanks to the team at relic and
wilds edge for all of their hard work
on the next title in the groundbreaking
age vampire series we're about to say
farewell but not before leaving you with
one more peek
at something coming to age of empires
four
[Music]